[Musique]
autour de lidl de proposer bientôt de
baisser le prix de sa baguette de 35 à
29 centimes d'euro le patron de l'ansej
ne cautionne pas cette démarche
commerciale mais se dit forcé contraints
de s'aligner sur concerant concurrent
leclerc un accident de voiture a eu lieu
près du lac de chalain impliquant cinq
lycéens dont quatre mineurs la
conductrice de 19 ans aurait perdu le
contrôle sur une plaque de verglas le
véhicule a ensuite chuté de 10 mètres
avant d'atterrir dans le lac un des
passagers a réussi à prévenir les
secours et est aujourd'hui hors de
danger les quatre autres jeunes n'ont
pas survécu mais dans un marché
concurrentiel
concurrentiels tels qu'on ne peut pas
l'idole mais même carrefour et où les
autres ne peuvent pas être 6 centimes 18
% plus cher que leclerc ne nous y
trompons pas la situation sanitaire est
encore tendue le nombre
d'hospitalisations reste très élevé et
le nombre de cas détectés est encore en
sensible augmentation
ça devient un véritable sketch
c'est à dire que la loi sur le pass
vaccinale n'est même pas en application
tout elle est encore donc conseil
constitutionnel que à compter donc lu
mercredi 2 février
tous les équipements notamment sportifs
et culturels qui accueillent du public
assis pour en retrouver un
fonctionnement à pleine capacité le
gouvernement qui a fait un cinéma
absolument incroyable anxiogène en
expliquant que c'était lui de la fin du
monde et qu'on devait accepter de
limiter l'intégralité de nos libertés
vient nous expliquer qui va procéder à
la levée d'un certain nombre de
contraintes le port du masque ne sera
plus exigé en extérieur à compter du
mercredi 16 février nous lèverons les
autres mesures le patron des députés
européens et rennes à strasbourg il
s'appelle jérôme rivière a rejoint eric
zemmour il était le porte parole de
marine le pen est une espèce de de gens
de mercenariat dans la vie politique
française qui ne touchent pas d'ailleurs
que reims en national puisque les élèves
en sont aussi victimes puis sûrement
d'autres mouvements de gauche dont on
s'intéresse moins aux fossés
s'interroger sur les motivations de ce
monsieur qui file vers un navire en
perdition où c'est à dire que il quitte
une candidate ne peut pas lui reprocher
d'aller à la soupe et effectivement j'ai
fait ce choix qui est un choix difficile
compliqué quand vous présidez une
délégation de 23 députés c'est le seul
poste institutionnelle du rassemblement
national quelque part la place est bonne
la place et chose si je puis dire jérôme
rivière à
les nourrir une aigreur incontestable
car ils espéraient des postes au sein du
rassemblement national que je
considérais qui ne pouvons obtenir ces
lots est un aigri et gris voilà ce que
dit l'entourage de marine le pen louis
mort et que ce n'est qu'une vicissitudes
de campagne de vous permet bien sûr je
comprends vous savez quand on quand on a
un
quand on prend un choc politique de
cette nature là on cherche des
explications et toujours garder à
l'esprit qui aura aussi le moment il
faut être capable de se rassembler
notamment au second tour pour avec un
objectif principal empêcher macro d'être
gratuite sachant que tout ça intervient
au moment où les syndicats appellent à
une nouvelle journée de mobilisation qui
devrait avoir lieu jeudi
expliquer pourquoi cette séquence fait
paul aimé des français en maillot de
bain dans 30 ans et de se tartiner de
crème solaire sur ben amos a la playa
cna action militante cette journaliste
de l'émission qui s'appelle anna cabana
pour ceux qui l'ignorent et bien c'est
la femme de jean michel blanquer qu'il a
épousée il ya quelques jours donc en
fait quand elle anime ce débat sur les
vacances de son mari en fait ce sont les
vacances auxquelles elle a elle-même ont
participé ce n'était pas une fête
c'était une séance de travail à bien et
là nous allons devoir faire une pause
pour dîner très bien vous allez repartir
après et après nous travaillons nous
travaillons d'arrache-pied jour et nuit
pour les françaises et les français et
pour les écoles